c'est juste ici devant ce snack situé au
quartier volga plage à fort-de-france
que mireille la mort aux 43 ans mère de
sept enfants a été touché par un tireur
en cagoule et son compagnon présent au
moment des faits témoigne la mère de mes
enfants afin balles perdues lesquels
aimante avec son bébé de sept mois dans
les bras devant ses deux derniers
enfants âgés de 6 ans et 9 ans quand
j'ai entendu le coup de feu ou savez
j'ai tourné la tête j'ai pensé à mes
enfants j'ai vu que l avait déjà bbg
projet sous les 2 autres elle m'a appelé
et m'a dit pro b b mamady matthieu
proulx me dit j'ai pris mes dix mais
j'ai vu qu'elle sentait pas bien précis
ces fonds des jeux des prix je ne m'a
pas aller ou d'un film massage cardiaque
mais si ce temps il était tout
simplement rassemblées sur cette place à
l'occasion de l'anniversaire d'une soeur
employés dans ce petit commerce de volga
plages allaient passer pour sa soeur
pour son anniversaire histoire de fêter
un petit correction il en fait en train
de manger on a tôt fait d'en manger vite
faire et puis on entre et après il a
fait un entraînement j'ai puis elle m'a
donné son dernier souffle dans mes bras
alors que je tenais notre petit pays de
6 mois de sept mois dans l'émoi un autre
membre de la famille plus légèrement
touchés étaient prises en charge par les
urgences hospitalières
selon les premiers éléments de l'enquêté
comme le confirme quelques personnes sur
le terrain six hommes encagoulés
lourdement mais ont été aperçus aux
environs de 22h dans les artères de ce
quartier populaire
règlement de compte ou pas certains
diront qu'ils étaient à la recherche de
nombreux récemment sorti de prison
déterminé à toucher leur cible ces
hommes encagoulés se seraient alors
livré à une véritable fusillade
j'ai entendu plusieurs détonations elle
était forte et très forte
et dire que les gens qui vous plaisir
fois oui j'ai enfin les résidents de
volga plages et autres membres
d'associations déplorant une nouvelle
fois ses actes de violence c'est tout
bateau arrive en salles et débarquer en
bateau
mais sa caf et a caché à cammas a
rappelé me tender d'appeler bachar
mauvais image soit on a pris des années
pour projet de faire bouger le quantité
d'essence positif met des jeunes en
l'activité rue un développement sur le
quartier
ce genre d'action des poissons appâts
puisse dessus un sens peut on faire
contre ça mais ça ne casse libre à
quelque part pour l'heure l'enquêté
confiée à la police judiciaire
les tireurs sont activement recherchés